doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness finds doctor strange and the
scarlet witch sharing more screen time
than ever before but what's their mcu
relationship all about and what's
different in the comics spoilers for
multiverse of madness ahead doctor
strange and the scarlet witch began
their mcu tenure in an oddly similar
fashion introduced in the same film and
through the same organization strange's
first appearance was in name only during
captain america the winter soldier when
cap falcon and black widow force double
agent jasper sitwell to confess who
hydra is targeting bruce banner steven
strange anyone who's a threat to hydra
scarlet witch is also introduced in
winter soldier in the film's mid-credits
scene moving through a hydra base baron
strucker tells a scientist about the
organization's many experiments finally
revealing their greatest success the
twins quicksilver and scarlet witch the
siblings are far from the confident
composed avengers they would one day
become but it's clear nonetheless the
innate power they possess by the end of
winter soldier both dr strange and
scarlett have officially entered the mcu
in both cases through hydra agents
discussing their grand plans
perhaps the biggest difference between
doctor strange and the scarlet witch is
the source and style of magic they wield
though both are world class wizards the
two climbed to that peak from opposite
sides of the magical mountain strange
spent his first few decades in an
entirely magic-less world i do not
believe in fairy tales about chakras or
energy or the power of belief there is
no such thing as spirit it was only
after a period of intense study and
practice that strange learned to wield
magic and the magic itself reflects that
organized effort as kevin feige told
comicbook.com of strange's magic it's
all about focus it's all about pulling
energies from other dimensions in an
organized and purposeful fashion feige
also compared strange's orderly magic
with wandas noting that while strange
learned as an adult to write in the
quote source code that shapes reality
wanda was born with awesome and
inexplicable power forcing her to spend
her whole life trying to control its
chaos or work within it
strange and wanda both share one
critically important facet in their
magical development
an infinity stone in doctor strange the
character is forced into a rushed
curriculum graduating to master of the
mystic arts somewhat by default when
cassilius's attacks warranted his
conscription into the war likewise wanda
was never formally educated merely poked
and prodded by scientists in between
periods of self-study as a child in
sokovia and again as a young woman at
the avengers compound yet both received
exponential magnifications of their
powers through connection to an infinity
stone at commer taj strange began
experimenting with the aya bagamoto
later revealed to house the time stone
his proficiency with the artifact led
him to becoming its keeper and he leaned
on its power arguably as much as he did
every other spell in his repertoire
likewise hydra used the mind stone to
amplify wanda's powers and channel them
into a more manipulatable form like
wanda's power in general the exact
nature of the mind stone's influence is
unknown but wandavision made it clear
that the stone helped lead wanda to her
ultimate destiny
the next in the long string of parallels
between strange and wanda is the nature
of their heroism and their place in
superhero society unlike the mcu's more
mainstage heroes such as captain america
iron man and thor neither wanda nor
strange have ever fit in with the core
avengers crowd strange's relationship
with the avengers is a relatively
straightforward one strange has never
been an avenger and what's more during
infinity war stark makes spider-man an
official avenger right in front of
strange and never offers the sorcerer
the same status though wanda did become
an official avenger at the end of age of
ultron her tenure was brief and marked
by active opposition to the group before
joining the team she actively fought
against them first protesting against
their presence in sokovia and then
joining ultron's campaign against them
and though she joined the avengers in
2015's age of ultron she left by 2016's
captain america civil war fighting
against iron man's registered avengers
she became a fugitive from the law and
then a prisoner her subsequent
enslavement of an entire town in new
jersey during one division certainly
didn't help her case for re-entry into
the group
though the two spellcasters never met
during infinity war both participated in
the defense of earth and its infinity
stones in similar conflicts with each
protecting their associated stone from
pairs of black order enforcers in new
york city strange fought alongside stark
wong and spider-man against the
formidable duo of call obsidian and
ebony ma his only goal was to protect
the time stone from falling into the
wrong hands which he accomplished for a
time similarly wanda fought alongside
vision cap black widow and falcon
against the duo of proxima midnight and
chorus glaive her only goal was to
protect the mind stone and the android
whose head it was lodged in which she
also accomplished for a time
both moved on to further battles with
strange fighting on titan and wanda
fighting in wakanda in both of their
cases the two sorcerers ended up coming
face to face with thanos himself
matching their might in one-in-one
contests with the mad titan
for both strange and wanda their
infinity war encounters with thanos
ended with grim pragmatic choices that
forced both to voluntarily lose that
which they coveted the most throughout
the film strange repeatedly expressed
his commitment to safeguarding the time
stone at any cost if it comes to saving
you or the kid
or the time stone
i will not hesitate to let either of you
die then after searching millions of
futures to find the key to defeating
thanos strange voluntarily hands him the
stone even the relative certainty of his
divination could not have made strange's
decision an easy one especially knowing
he would be snapped out of existence
wanda too was forced to conceive the
stone she had so adamantly protected in
her case however the decision was even
more heart-wrenching and desperate as
the stones sat within the skull of
vision the man she loved and her only
recourse was to destroy it through
bitter tears wanda succeeded fragmenting
the stone and killing vision as if her
trauma was not enough thanos then used
the time stone to undo the entire
sequence of events
when infinity war ended both strange and
wanda were gone snapped by thanos into
dust though both had played their parts
admirably they had failed to prevent
thanos from accomplishing his goal both
were fated to make their grand return as
act 3 of avengers endgame commenced
snapped back into existence by the hulk
both fought in the battle of earth
against thanos and his armies
you took
everything from me
i don't even know who you are
you will
strange helped shield the entire
battlefield from the destructive cannons
of thanos's flagship and single-handedly
held back a flood that threatened to
drown the heroes wanda inflamed with
rage at the death of vision used her
powers to assault thanos head on and
even proved herself the stronger power
as she shattered the titan's blade
fractured his armor and nearly crushed
him to death
one of the most tenuous but ultimately
tantalizing links between strange and
wanda involves the ancient spell tome
known as the darkhold and its possible
existence throughout marvel movies and
tv shows it began in doctor strange when
multiple fans noticed one important
spell book noticeably absent then when
the infamous darkhold appeared in agents
of shield fans connected the conspicuous
dots the book appeared again in one
division when agatha harkness used its
secrets to enhance her own sorcery
forging a chain from all these links we
reach the most likely conclusion that
the darkhold was stolen from the library
at camartage where strange studied and
found its way to harkness who used it to
manipulate wanda during one division
when we last saw wanda before multiverse
of madness she was studying the book's
dark ancient secrets making it clear
that strange would either find the book
or detect its influence on wanda
strange's second movie doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness sees the good
doctor and the scarlet witch in direct
conflict for the first time having
delved deeply into the darkhold wanda
begins the film under the book's
insidious influence the multiverse it's
dangerous she is cold cruel and wildly
violent and she brings all of that
wickedness to the forefront in her quest
to capture america chavez and steal the
young woman's ability to travel the
multiverse her success would mean
chavez's death and the death of another
universe's wanda and potentially even
the collapse of the entire multiverse
and naturally that doesn't fly with
strange the two wage a magical war
across realities with strange giving his
all to protect the multiverse chavez and
even wanda herself this is going to be
fun ultimately the witch's quest leads
her to ruin and in the process the
partial corruption of strange as well
the film's final shot is strange on his
knees struck with pain and bearing the
creepy third eye that we last saw on the
evil version of strange corrupted by the
darkhold but in the comics this would be
a physical manifestation of the eye of
agamotto
in the comics one recurring theme
between the two is the doctor-patient
relationship which makes sense given
strange's medical degree and former
career and makes even more sense given
strange's comprehensive knowledge of all
things arcane the pairing of strange's
two fields of expertise makes him
uniquely suited to handle ailments when
it comes to fellow magical beings and
wanda is no exception strange was on
hand in vision and the scarlet witch
number 12 to deliver wanda's twin baby
boys he was also the most effective at
treating wanda's psychosis in avengers
disassembled understanding her reality
manipulating symptoms better than any
though his choice of treatment in the
latter and its follow-up house of m
arguably did as much harm as they did
good his strategy was nonetheless the
most informed of anyone's
the most common form that strange and
wanda's relationship takes is that of
mentor and mentee strange is more
experienced than wanda more educated and
more in control of his powers largely
due to his access to magical materials
and manuscripts that remained hidden
throughout wanda's formative years a
telling recent example came in the
miniseries empire x-men in which one of
wanda's attempts at atonement backfires
in attempting to undo her no more mutant
spell in which she de-powered millions
of mutants at once wanda cast a spell to
revive the millions of mutant slain
during the massacre at genosha instead
she raised an army of mutant zombies
millions in number and still
semi-superpowered strange was able to
undo the wayward spell but not without
taking multiple occasions to lecture
wanda on her misuse of magic and lack of
thorough training
the most recent relationship to form
between strange and wanda is that of a
co-worker in the ongoing series strange
academy strange created a school for
magically and supernaturally adept
children to harness their innate gifts
and study their craft the school accepts
students from all walks of life death
and undeath and so strange hired a
faculty even more varied and powerful
than their pupils in issue number two we
learned that wanda teaches a course for
which she is uniquely qualified known as
elements of chaos magic the official
course description lists wanda as the
foremost practitioner of the most
volatile magic alongside professors more
accustomed to the orderly side of magic
as well as elemental sorcerers like
magic and damon hellstrom wander rounds
out the academy's staff well even more
valuable is her experience in the
dangers of uncontrolled emotions and
using magic as an anesthetic
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]